>> ROSIE O'DONNELL REALLY,
REALLY HATES TRUMP.
BUT UNLIKE MOST PEOPLE IN HER
WORLD WHO REALLY HATE TRUMP, SHE
CAN CLAIM IT'S NOT A NEW THING.
SHE'S BEEN HATING TRUMP FOR MANY
YEARS.
SHE'S NO CLOSER TO WINNING THAT
DEBATE.
SHE STILL HAS TO THE RECOVERED
FROM THE 2016 ELECTION.
HERE'S PART OF IT.
>> WE ARE GOING TO RIGHT THE
SHIP.
THERE'S NO WAY HE'LL PREVAIL
BECAUSE HE'S EVIL AND DARK.
I ALWAYS THOUGHT WHY DIDN'T THEY
COUNTERPROGRAM HIS RALLIES.
HE WANTS TO SEND THE MILITARY TO
THE BORDER.
I WANT TO SEND THE MILITARY TO
THE WHITE HOUSE TO GET HIM.
[LAUGHTER]
>> MARTIAL LAW.
SHE THINKS THAT'S A GOOD IDEA.
>> YOU'VE BEEN HERE ALL YOUR
LIFE.
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE A FAMOUS ACTOR.
IF I WAS RUNNING THE HOLLYWOOD
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, I WOULD
TELL HER TO PULL BACK.
YOU'RE EMBARRASSING US.
>> IT WAS A JOKE, A THINLY
VEILED JOKE.
THAT WAS INSANE.
THAT'S A COUP.
>> Sean: DON'T OTHER PEOPLE IN
HER WORLD SAY, "LOOK, ROSIE, WE
GET IT, YOU DON'T LIKE TRUMP.
BUT YOU'RE DISCREDITING YOURSELF
AND THE REST OF US BY ACTING
LIKE A MENTAL PATIENT ON TV.
DON'T DO THAT."
>>THAT SOUNDS ENTIRELY
REASONABLE.
WHY WOULD SOMETHING LIKE THAT
HAPPEN.
I KNOW ROSIE.
I KNEW HER BACK IN THE DAY.
WE WERE VERY FRIENDLY AND
WONDERFUL.
I DON'T KNOW THAT SHE WOULD TALK
TO ME NOW.
BUT I DISAGREE WITH HER.
AND I WOULD BE HAPPY TO SIT
CROSS FROM HER AND SAY, "I
DISAGREE.
AND EVEN ON THAT SHOW, ALL THEY
DID WAS LAUGH.
WHY DIDN'T ANYBODY OFFER A
DISSENTING OPINION.
>> MARTIAL LAW?
HOW OFTEN DO YOU HEAR STUFF LIKE
THAT HERE AT DINNER?
>> MONDAY THROUGH SUNDAY.
>> SO IT'S UBIQUITOUS HERE.
>> I'LL HEAR IT FROM SOME OF THE
ACTORS.
BUT THEN WE'LL GO THROUGH AND
SHOOTING SOMETHING.
AND THEN THEY'RE LIKE, "HEY, I'M
WITH YOU."
>>THAT'S SUCH AN INTERESTING
POINT.
AND I'VE NOTICED THIS EXACT
THING.
HOW DIFFERENT ARE THE OPINIONS
OF THE CREWS?
>> I WOULD SAY THEY'RE
DIAMETRICALLY OPPOSED.
>> DON'T THE ACTORS AT SOME
POINT SAY, I'M SUPPOSED TO BE ON
THE SIDE OF THE AVERAGE PERSON,
THE UNDERDOG.
I'M SURRENDERED BY UNDERDOGS,
BUT I HATE THEM FROM THEIR
VIEWS.
>> ALL WE HEAR IS WHAT WE WANT
TO HEAR, MOST OF THE TIME.
I'M PUTTING MYSELF IN THAT CAMP
BECAUSE I AM AN ACTOR.
I TRAVEL THE WORLD.
I DO THINGS THAT I THINK HAVE
SOME SUBSTANCE.
I'M IN BAD PLACES.
BUT A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE,
YOU'RE CODDLES AS AN ACTOR AND
TOLD YOU'RE GREAT ALL THE TIME.
THEIR OPINION MEANS MORE THAN
THE GUY CLAPPING.
>> IF YOU'RE MAKING $10 MILLION